today I'm joined by the author of six
International best-selling books you
will know him for the 48 Laws of Power
The Art of Seduction and the laws of
human nature
some consider his work to be and I quote
evil but he believes he's just being a
realist however I will leave it up to
you to come to your own conclusions
Robert Greene welcome to the show great
to have you here how are you I'm fine
thank you for having me Leah thank you
for flying all the way out to Los
Angeles just for me I'm deeply honored
no I'm honored to have you it's my
pleasure your books are truly
fascinating
um the work that you do has been very
beneficial for my life for many people's
lives so
um thank you for joining us
my pleasure I have a lot of questions
for you and I think the first place that
I want to start is really understanding
why as individuals do we need to play
these kind of Mind Games manipulation
persuasion dark psychology why can't we
just be
well if we were perfect animals if we
were descended from Angels instead of
chimpanzees
yeah that would be great if we lived in
the Garden of Eden but we don't we were
expelled from the Garden of Eden many
many many millions of years ago and we
have a dark side
and I'm not saying that you need to be a
manipulator in life I was not somebody
who was like that I was actually quite
naive when I entered the Work World at
the ripe young age of 18. I've had 80
different jobs and I've witnessed every
kind of manipulation you can imagine and
my idea is there most people are nice
most people aren't thinking about what
they can get out of other people but
there's a small percentage you can put
whatever number you want on it you can
say five percent something like that
maybe more of people who are kind of
conniving who are always thinking about
their own agenda who are looking at you
right now what can I get out of Leia how
can I use her for something right and if
you're naive and stupid like I often was
and you make mistakes your life gets
full of drama and you become miserable
and depressed you can fall into holes
and you don't even realize why I can
give you an example
law number one of the 48 Laws of Power
is never outshine the master as you know
right yeah okay I violated that law
several times I was working on a
television show as a researcher and I
had by far my my work got by far the
most stories produced I was the best
researcher they ever had
and this my boss kept getting on me and
was constantly needling me and finally I
got really tired of it and I quit but
then it was very upsetting to me why if
I'm producing the best results why am
why is she like harassing me
and it made me very upset and it kind of
turned me off from from working in
television
and I didn't realize till later on that
I had ouch on the master I was doing so
well my results were so good so many
people liked me because I can at times
have a likable personality believe it or
not that she was thinking he's better
than I am and it she doesn't ADM people
don't admit that to themselves they come
up with another excuse in their mind
like Robert is a bad person there's
something wrong with him right but
seriously deep below what motivates
their behavior is insecurity and envy I
was fired and I was miserable if I had
read the 48 Laws of Power before I had
written it I would have realized Robert
you've got to tone down your colors here
a little bit you have to fit in a little
better don't try so hard and then things
would have worked out more smoothly so
that's what the book is for the sharks
in the world and there are plenty of
sharks out there they don't need the 48
Laws of Power it's already in their DNA
they understand it it's more for the
people like me and perhaps like you who
enter the world a bit naive and full of
illusions
interesting this is something which you
possibly experience we spoke earlier and
you're talking about how you studied
ancient Greek right that's what you you
said you met you studied so how did you
learn that this is how humans operate
did is it literally just personal
experience throughout your life
yeah I mean
um you know I'm not going to go into my
family history I have wonderful parents
so don't get me wrong
um but you know uh probably there's
something up in my nature where
maybe it's my own insecurities or
whatever but I don't I'm a little bit
suspicious because I've been hurt by
people right and I'm so I'm I tend as a
writer I tend to always be observing
people I've been observing people like
that since I was four years old really
basically and um you develop kind of a
muscle for that a kind of way of picking
up non-verbal cues and seeing through
people and seeing what their true
motivations are so
I've made a lot of mistakes in life you
know and my path up until I wrote the 48
Laws of Power was very Rocky I was
probably maybe 38 or so when I started
the 48 Laws of Power more like 37. I was
pretty much a failure in life up until
then and I had many many pitfalls I had
done many mistakes in life and it made
me unhappy and so
the books I write and the powers of
observation I've developed are to really
help people out there to not be
constantly making these mistakes that's
the spirit that the book is written in
so would you say the 48 Laws of Power
was almost like a reflection on your own
life going back and thinking where did I
make a mistake understanding the mistake
and then sort of putting that down on
paper
mostly a lot of the laws do have that
but you know law number 16 crush your
enemy totally
first of all I don't really have any
enemies that I know of although I'm sure
I do and I wouldn't ever crush them
because I'm really too nice for that so
that kind of law is more how I observe
the world you know so it's not things
that all all the laws have to do with me
would happen to me it's things I've
observed so I worked in Hollywood before
I wrote the book I wrote for film
directors Etc and screenwriters and I
saw a lot of kind of nasty crap going on
people doing things that quite frankly
struck me as downright immoral right how
they treat people and I was very struck
by that and so um I don't you know I
don't want to I didn't want to be like
that I didn't want to have Behavior like
that I just wanted to understand it I
want to understand where this came from
and so that you know so a lot of it is
observing people in power
and you know like crush your enemy
totally when I wrote the 48 Laws of
Power
at the time this goes back quite a while
why way back even before you were born
maybe there was a thing called Netscape
Navigator which was the the E major kind
of uh it was like Safari or Windows back
then
and Microsoft ended up buying Netscape
Navigator and crushing it and
eliminating it completely and I was
thinking this is the real dynamic in the
business world it's a merciless ruthless
World particularly in Tech where the
goal is to crush your competitors but
nobody talks about it that way right and
so my observations personal observations
my own experience and things that I
observed in the news the kind of stuff
that people don't talk about because
when it comes to power
we're almost embarrassed by it we're
almost embarrassed by that part of
ourselves that wants power we all want
to pretend that we're such good Noble
saintly individuals we don't want to
admit that we might occasionally
manipulate that we might be interested
in power that we might be ambitious and
quite frankly that really offends me I
like honesty let's look at the human
being and who we are in in a real way
and be kind of comfortable with the fact
that we have this other side to us the
crucial enemy entirely law is really
fascinating
I remember I went to Cambodia a few
years ago and I learned about the
dictator Paul Potts and he went after
the children so that he so that the
children didn't come back
for didn't come back didn't grow up and
take revenge basically so did he kill
them yeah he killed the babies there's a
tree called the baby tree where he
smashed babies against the tree in
Cambodia so I didn't know about that
yeah so that is interesting because it's
it's not just in business but it's in
war you know crush your enemy entirely
so nobody comes back to get you and I
understand that when you were younger
you were fascinated by War yeah
I admit it it's not very politically
correct these days but um you know my
father served in the Navy and I grew up
was the World War II wasn't that distant
to memory right and I was fascinated by
it probably the earliest books I read
all had to do with World War II and
battles and I just love the idea of
strategy but also the drama of it you
know to this day my wife kind of we joke
about it I go to sleep watching war
movies or the war Channel because I find
it very relaxing
you know I love the pageantry I love the
drama I love the fact that it's life and
death now I've never been a soldier so
it's very easy to say from the Comforts
of where I am now but the fact of your
life is at risk you're fighting for your
Homeland you're fighting for some cause
and
you have to think in a very deep way
right now I am the I am devouring any
article I can about the war between
Ukraine and Russia I'm completely
obsessed with it strategically it is
absolutely one of the most amazing
modern phenomena it's the greatest
strategic
um learning office thing since World War
II it's absolutely amazing the
ukrainians are kicking ass they're doing
fantastic things and I'm so excited
because first of all I'm Jewish my
family comes from Odessa so I'm
Ukrainian at heart I was in Ukraine
two two three years ago to give a talk I
love the people there it's a wonderful
place Tech Wise It's very modern
sophisticated in it and it's a
burgeoning democracy and I'm not in you
know a Putin I would say what I feel
about Putin but the fact that this
Underdog is using all of these take is
leveraging it's it's truly asymmetrical
Warfare and having to be so creative on
the battlefield because there are the
underdog and they're just doing amazing
things with a lot of United States help
so
I don't know why you're asking me about
my interest in Warfare but I I am
fascinated well because I
wrote a whole book on that 33 Strategies
of War
which was my third book
originally I was going to write a book
on the history of human stupidity which
is a subject that interests me a lot
um but the Publishers said Robert
they don't think that's going to be a
very marketable topic so I immediately
segued into Warren strategy because it
is something that has fascinated me for
many many many years but the the task
that I gave myself in that book was I
want to make war relevant to your
everyday life right so I think of
business as pure strategy as pure
competition it is like Warfare right in
so many ways and so but life can is
involves conflict you know conflict with
your brother conflict with your spouse
conflict with your colleagues Etc and
learning to be strategic in life is
extremely important so I wanted to take
Napoleon Bonaparte who I think is one of
the greatest generals that ever lived
and make it applicable to your daily
life so that you could apply it right
now to your business that you know to to
the business that you're growing so um
it is applicable to everything there's a
Time nice guys finish last you called
yourself a nice guy early or you said
you're too nice sometimes so I'd like to
get a take on what's wrong with being a
nice person
well I'm not that nice
it's I I disguise a dark side I disguise
I'm extremely competitive and I'm very
ambitious right
um there's nothing wrong with being nice
it's that you're going to get pushed
around
if what you want to do is get things
done in life and to me that's that's
what I want that's what I live for
writing books changing people's lives it
could be creating a business it could be
being a great athlete it could be
you know whatever it is you want to get
things done you want to accomplish
things and if you're too nice you're
going to get pushed around in life right
I do a lot of Consulting with people in
various Fields a lot of them are in the
entertainment industry right artists
actors Etc and that's the problem that
they have right they're very nice people
they're so nice at heart and they've had
to learn if they want to succeed in a
tough environment like Hollywood that if
you're nice you're not going to make it
anywhere you're not going to get
anywhere so it's not like you become a
nasty evil person I don't want that to
happen to you Leia because you seem very
nice it's just that you understand that
there are people out there with bad
intentions and you don't get emotionally
entangled in everything they do you're
able to step back and be strategic in
life and say if I say that that'll get
me in more trouble it'll create more
conflict what if I act in this way to
kind of diffuse the situation so
actually being strategic is a way to
kind of lessen the amount of drama in
your life and give it more peace it's a
way to avoid many conflicts as well
anyone
constantly
um like Embrace these laws constantly
because like you said I would consider
myself to be a nice person but I'm aware
and skeptical of uh the world and you
know the harsh realities of what's out
there so incorporating these um
different techniques sort of exhausts me
because it's not natural for me so what
does someone like me do well what what
exhausts you exactly tell me what
exhausts do let's go into this okay like
the like the Mind Games and the strategy
having to really think deep about you
know how do I approach this situation
right whether it's like conflict okay so
I have an issue you know somebody's
disrespecting me
you know how do I how do I set her
straight you know or do I just go
because I just don't want the conflict
sort of navigating that relationship in
order to maintain my power and so you
know I might be young but I'm but I'm
not stupid and I know what I'm doing you
know having that situation is is
difficult like it's exhausting for me
well flip flip the script here a little
bit and change how you look at it let's
say you're dealing with someone who's
disrespecting you or who you suspect is
is not up to anything good that maybe
they they're using you in some way
and you step back and even though it's
exhausting you think about it you go
here I can do A B C or D in this
situation A will lead to more conflict I
don't want that b my work c d looks
really good actually if I do D it'll
probably surprise this person he or she
and you know they'll be surprised and
they'll back off Etc and then you do it
you apply it and lo and behold it works
how exciting so instead of exhausting
it's exciting you've avoided a battle
you've avoided a conflict perhaps you've
turned an enemy into a into an ally or
you got rid of them completely what what
Joy you should have it should fill you
with excitement it should fill you with
I'm learning about life I'm becoming an
adult I'm not just a baby that reacts to
everything that gets emotional goes why
are people I'm I'm standing up for
myself you know women particularly
nowadays need that kind of it's
difficult it's harder for a woman in the
world today than than for a man and you
need that ability to be able to to stand
up and be tough you know how to deal
with people it's a great feeling you
feel liberated it's not exhausting if
you do it right it shouldn't be
exhausting what is exhausting is being
stupid and making mistakes and having
that conflict go on and on and on and on
week after week that's the much more
exhausting um you're absolutely right I
know I am of course you are of course
you are um so we spoke earlier and I was
saying how the guardian called your work
evil
um but you obviously believe that you're
a realist so I'm interested in getting
your opinion on that distinction between
evil and realism and do you think that
we're all just sort of self-serving
narcissists answer the question we are
we are all narcissists and I make that
point in my book the laws of human
nature not to like make you feel bad and
guilty about yourself but to point out
that we all have Tendencies to be
self-absorbed
and when I wrote that chapter in the
laws of human nature it made me realize
Robert you are actually quite a
narcissist you have many of these
tendencies that you arrive about in fact
you have all of them right and it was
kind of unpleasant to be honest with you
it made me confront myself made me
confront some of the more unpleasant
aspects of my own character so yeah we
all we do all have that tendency but
you know
I people who moralize a lot kind of
really annoy me they really rub me the
wrong way because I think we all have a
dark side we all can be selfish we all
have motivated occasionally not always
by by selfish desires etc etc we all can
do things that are manipulative right
and the people who tend to screen the
loudest Robert Green is evil Robert
Greene is immoral how ugly you know
creating more manipulation they're the
ones who are the most passive aggressive
they're the ones who are the most
Insidious when it comes to power not
always but often they are because they
can't admit that they have this side to
their personality we all do
let's just get down on our hands and
knees and say yes we are human beings
yes we want Power yes we can manipulate
journalists are the most manipulative
people on the planet I know I used to be
a journalist right and so you know I can
give you an example about five years ago
no more like eight years ago some
Australian newspaper I can't remember a
really big one I want to do kind of a
hit piece on me they didn't tell me that
they sent a journalist over to interview
me and I could sense right away that all
of his questions were kind of like that
Guardian thing
your book is read in prisons Robert what
do you think about that people in prison
like it you know kind of tainting me as
if I'm a criminal Etc
and then you know and I went on a charm
offensive I was very nice and I defended
myself I even invited the guy on a bike
riding group at the park you know I was
very friendly Etc he wrote the article
basically saying Robert Greene isn't
really evil he's actually nice and smart
etcetera or whatever I don't know and
they never ran the piece right
journalists are so goddamn [__]
manipulative they never tell you what
their intentions are so get off your
[__] high horse Mr Guardian
journalist because I'm sure in your life
you've done all kinds of things from the
48 Laws of Power it really annoys me as
you can say yeah yes people's hypocrisy
their lack of honesty the fact that they
think that they are holier than you are
they're always having the moral the
upper moral hand you know
it's not true that's what I like about
your work because it's just calling a
spade a spade you know this is what
humans are and I think we actually live
in a world now where people prefer to
pretend to be a good person than
actually be a good person virtue
signaling not that excuse me no you're
fine yeah absolutely um but speaking of
that um that side of people that we all
have so you I think you refer to it as
the dark shadow so can you explain the
shadow side yeah so can you explain what
the dark shadow is and is it something
that's within everyone and then also how
do we harness that how do we bring that
into our lives and use it in a healthy
way yes well the way I explain it is the
following I explain it in the laws of
human nature I have a chapter on it
is that when you were a child three four
years old
you were like a complete person
you with your brother Gideon you could
be the nicest sweetest person and then
the next moment an hour later you're
punching him you're pulling his hair out
you're saying nasty things behind his
back to your mother children are like
that right they don't really haven't
learned they haven't been socialized yet
they have a complete they have all these
different emotions some good some not so
good right and this makes them kind of
human and healthy in a way and then what
happens is you get older you said Leia
Gideon you have to be a nicer person you
have to behave you have to be polite you
have to fit in and the teachers you go
to school and they're starting to say
don't do that do this you want to fit in
you know don't don't out don't misbehave
etc etc you feel all of these pressures
as you get older going through high
school with your peers Etc and all of
that dark emotion that you had when you
and girls have it just as much as boys
believe me all that dark energy you had
those kind of desires sometimes to maybe
even heard a person because you're angry
or you're upset about something and act
out on it they get crushed they get
repressed they go into this Shadow side
so if you have this take this round ball
that is a child that's complete emotion
half of it gets cut off excuse me and
becomes a shadow so you have half a head
and the shadow goes back here and you're
always behaving like you're the nicest
sweetest person but I know even you Leia
right now you have a shadow you have
these kind of desires right you're
ambitious you're powerful you want Power
Etc right you may not be admitting it to
yourself but it is there that dark
energy doesn't go away and what you
happen what happens to people if you
look in the news
suddenly some celebrities some
politician will do something that seems
very out of character right it could be
some sexual Escapade it could be
something they say that seems
insensitive then they'll go oh that
wasn't me I apologize it's not what I
intended to mean you know that's not who
I am
and that's where the shadow expresses
itself because it's been repressed and
it wants to come out so you can't get
rid of it you can't like find a way to
to destroy it it's there it's lurking
and it's going to influence you the more
you try and crush it down so the the
solution is to stop to turn around and
be honest with yourself I'm all about
honesty right
and to look at yourself deeply and say I
have these desires I do feel Envy
sometimes we all feel Envy you know I do
have aggressive impulses right I am I
can be very self-absorbed I can be quite
irrational at times
etc etc just admit it look in the mirror
and admit it and then the next step is
what do I do with that knowledge and
when it comes to your dark side I say
it has all of this energy your good
saintly side has like 20 percent of the
energy uh and and the dark energy is
like 80 it's got more behind it right
when you're angry or cetera there's more
energy there's more that adrenaline
flowing right it's powerful stuff
you don't want you want to use it in
some way so you want to channel it you
want to be aware of it you want to
channel it into your ambition into your
competitive impulses I Robert Greene an
incredibly competitive person I'm going
to write the best damn book out there
that I can right I'm going to sell as
many copies as I can I'm not hurting
anybody by saying that am I I'm you know
I'm actually helping a lot of people by
writing a book that's strong in some I'm
not really trying to tout myself I'm not
that much of a narcissist I'm just using
it as an example right okay so I'm going
to channel it into being competitive and
ambitious okay or let's say
um I'm I'm more of a issue-oriented
person there's Injustice in this world
right you know the metoo movement or
whatever movement there is and you're
angry that makes you upset instead of
whining and complaining and bitching on
Facebook about it organize and do
something right and channel that energy
into Purdue to helping people into
contributing to society instead of just
sitting on your at your computer and
trolling people and saying all kinds of
negative nasty comments actually
organize and get something done you if
you're in sports I talk about an athlete
like Kobe Bryant who might is like my
idol was one I just loved Kobe watching
Kobe he was had a lot of dark energy he
was extremely competitive he channeled
into being the greatest basketball
player on the planet for a while right
that's how you use Utah and I tell
artists filmmakers writers Etc
channel that anger that you have and put
it into your work it's extremely
powerful people are attracted to it
because we're so repressed we're so
politically correct we're so like
uncomfortable with ourselves that when
we see a politician or an artist
expressing those emotions
wow that's exciting that's great that's
where the power in the dark side lies
yeah it's so fascinating because I can
relate I think some of my best work is
done from a place of competitiveness
like what for instance like if I see
somebody doing better than me I'll be
like
okay I need to step up my game now so
you're not as nice as you were
pretending to be I am nice competition
is healthy because it's because the
other person as well because then I'll
do better I'm doing a healthy
competition
um do you think
Um this can ever go too far
um you know whereby people use
um these techniques this you know the
manipulation they talk about and they
use it in their personal life now and
not just in their business life well you
might be referring like excuse me to The
Art of Seduction for instance
um and it's interesting because I get a
lot of emails from men and women about
my books and I was for a while getting
emails from women who are saying you
know this man used the particular tactic
from The Art of Seduction it hurt me a
lot
but then they were thanking me for the
fact that they opened I opened their
eyes to what they were about what they
were doing so that they won't let this
happen again because the worst thing
that happens in these situations and if
the man used my book to hurt them I feel
terrible and in certain cases where it
was clear to me that maybe that happened
I tried to help the woman give her
advice as best as I could that wasn't my
intention writing the book because it's
a book that is for men and women to
seduce not just it's not just about the
male Seducer the worst thing that could
happen when this if you're the victim
here
is you don't understand and when it
comes to seduction it's very complicated
because your feelings of love
and you're very vulnerable
and you're not necessarily always
thinking straight right and when
somebody manipulates and then leaves you
or does something like that
it's very traumatic and it can take
months and you don't understand what
happened and you blame yourself
oftentimes you go what did I do wrong
why did I do this why did I you know and
my book is opening your eyes to these
tactics these psychological tactics that
men and women can use so you can
understand them it's also I'm not going
to say that it's just for that purpose
because it's also a book teaching you
how to seduce if that's what you want
but um yes there are people who go too
far with these things for sure right and
I don't know if they necessarily are
reading my book some of them are and
maybe I am contributing to that and I
feel bad I would feel bad about that but
most of the emails I get from and it's
anecdotal mind you I understand is this
opened my eyes to what really happened
to what this person was doing it made my
life easier in the long run so I'm not
so naive I'm not so stupid I could read
you really long extremely moving
um emails that I've got messages that
I've gotten many from women saying how
much it helped them now to recognize a
toxic male Seducer in their life that's
so fascinating so you know when people
say your work is evil it's like well you
know it also has the adverse effect as
well opens people's eyes as to you know
what's going on so I I was I'm really
fascinated by this particular topic can
you walk me through the different the
different types of seduces and how how
men and women overlap because I
understand you know men and women can be
the same so how do they overlap and how
do they differ in their seduction
techniques I I identify nine types of
seducers and I'm trying to tell you out
there in the world that you one of those
types fits you
there might be two types but generally
there's one that dominates and you might
have a second that's kind of a minor or
a third even right so I want you to
realize hey I'm a Coquette
yes I'm the natural yes I'm a siren if
you're a woman or I'm a rake if I'm a
man
and then reading about it you're able to
make this you're able to kind of
emphasize it more be more strategic use
it to better effect right okay so it's
kind of a natural quality that you have
because the worst kind of seducers are
in the in the world are those who've
read The Art of Seduction or the game
and they're out there applying it like
it's a science like it's chess or
something and it's awful and usually
particularly women can see right through
it this person is too cold they're too
calculating right so bringing out your
natural quality and recognizing that
you're a siren is the most powerful
female seductress of them all it's a
woman that is very powerful kind of
Sexual Energy but also energy in general
and there's a slight masculine touch to
them right it's kind of powerful like a
Cleopatra or a Marilyn Monroe and it has
men are very visual creatures we judge
things by how they look and they know
how to create this appearance that's
almost like Mythic very powerful and
Theatrical and a true siren there's not
a man on the planet who could resist
true siren the flip side of that is the
rake the male rake who's a man who's
obsessed with women he can never have
enough he understands their psychology
very deeply even identifies with them in
a way he has a slight feminine touch to
him and he said he understands The Power
of Words women's weakness of men is
visual women's weakness is often words
he knows how to kind of ensnare them and
all these beautiful sounding words and
say the right things and write the right
messages Etc right on and on and on
there are these different types the
Coquette is a devastating uh Seducer who
blows hot and cold etc etc and so I'm
trying to instruct you to identify with
one of them and bring them out now which
one did you identify with maybe more
than natural ah yeah I mean you could
maybe say I don't think the siren I
don't think so I can be masculine in
terms of like the power but I don't
think that's natural I feel like I put
that on for a work environment but I
think more natural yeah
which one do you identify with
well it's a little bit embarrassing but
I'm older now but when I was in my 20s I
was a rake okay yeah but I'm I'm what
you call a reformed rate a reformed rake
what does that mean it means I've been
corralled and put into the pen there's a
fence around me are you able to like
leave to escape the fence it means you
met a lovely woman and now you have a
wife and you're happy and that's the
better way of putting it again the off
seduction is a fascinating one how did
you learn all of those different types
of
uh seduces and also what made you want
to go down that route you know you've
done laws of human nature there's power
and now it's it's more sexual so what
made you go down that path what was the
second book I wrote so um
well I've always been interested in
seduction
um as a form of excuse me as a form of
power right
and um as I explained in my 20s
it was it was like this sort of
fascinating game for me right and I
enjoyed it very much and it kind of um
got a lot of my
it kind of you know it was like Warfare
for me the strategies involved you know
I wasn't cold about it but it was
exciting it was an exciting process and
then I lived in Paris
uh when I was 21 I worked in a hotel
right I was a receptionist in a hotel
and it was a hotel where all of these
models stayed
and there was this man who would come to
the hotel he wasn't staying there this
tall very handsome Brazilian man named
Eduardo I hope he's still alive out
there
he was the most brilliant Seducer I've
ever seen in my life
and I was fascinated by him and it
wasn't so much what he did or said it
was just his energy the way he carried
himself
he was so relaxed he was so confident
about himself so secure and within
that it was like women founded devilish
they just couldn't resist him and I saw
him do all kinds of terrible things and
women would forgive him for these Deeds
he just never got defensive he never got
reactive he was always open engaging
gracious
now wow this man is what power yeah I
wish I could be like that you know and
so I was fascinated by the process and
nobody writes a book about how to seduce
it's kind of this myth about well a
woman just puts on a sexy dress and you
know does the right things and set her
in a man just you know applies it with
alcohol or whatever no there's
psychology involved there's a way to
make a person fall in love with you and
that process of making people fall in
love with you applies to sex and a
relationship it applies to your office
and getting people to like you there's
no sex involved but you can be a social
Seducer it applies to politics like John
F Kennedy and television and seducing a
whole country
it applies to marketing any product
right so the process of getting lowering
people's resistance and making them want
to buy your product to vote for you to
like you in the office it's all the same
I wanted to study it and I wanted to
reveal that to the world
it's so fascinating and I'm sure
watching Eduardo with all these
different women was was the start of
something for you yeah
you know the the best Seducer probably
on a part to Eduardo was 50 Cent
he was he was pretty incredible because
I wrote a book with 50. you know and I
witnessed him on the phone
mostly on the hearing him on phone
conversations with various celebrities
wow that guy's got game I wish I wish I
could be on that level as well he was
like the second greatest Seducer maybe
equal to Eduardo well um what type of
Seducer would you say he is he's a rake
he's also the charismatic because 50 has
tremendous Charisma I don't know between
those two I'd I wanted to ask you about
your relationship with 50 because I've
seen the movie
um so I sort of I understand
um the hustle that he had to go through
um obviously you like you mentioned you
have the book the 50th law so what did
you learn from 50 Cent well the book
that we wrote together is about
fearlessness and the power that you have
when you don't when you're not afraid in
life and it's not it's not just like
fearlessness in battle or something it's
kind of a calm energy the things don't
upset you but you're able to stay within
yourself you're not afraid of failure
you're not afraid of doing something bad
you're not afraid of being different or
weird you're not afraid of death
Etc
and when I met 50 I was struck by his
calmness you know you think of him as
being this Thug this kind of nasty guy
who's you know with all these beaves
pushing people around
he's not he's like very sweet and nice
he's very calm
right he's fearless and I always thought
that I'm kind of a Fearless person I'm
always been sort of a risk taker in life
and I thought I'm not nearly as Fearless
as 50 and he showed me a level of how to
operate in like negotiating situations
in meetings how to deal with stress I
learned a lot about that kind of energy
that he had there and how I can
sometimes
it's not just what you say or do as I
said with a Seducer but it's how you
carry yourself right I wrote a lot I
write a lot about non-verbal behavior in
this world and people of power often
have a way of carrying themselves
that's very powerful right and he he was
like a lion he had that kind of power
and energy to him where he'd be in a
meeting he didn't have to ever say
anything and people be watching him Etc
it's a center of attention I kind of
looked at that very closely and I go I
can learn from this how did you meet him
he was a big fan of the 50 of 48 Laws of
Power he told me
um
that you know he grew up on the street
of South Side Queens dealing crack you
know let's you know that's just what it
was you know he was a hustler at a very
early age he dealt with all kinds of
dangerous situations people trying to
kill him left right and Center
but nothing prepared him for the music
business it was infinitely more Sinister
and dark and harsh and power hungry than
anything on the streets of South Side
Queens
and the 48 Laws of Power helped him
immensely navigate that Sharky
environment of the music industry and
the record labels and so
he loved that book a lot and he wanted
to meet me
I think he had the ulterior motive which
I didn't know at the time of getting
maybe to write a book or doing something
together which I didn't think of at the
time but he wanted to meet me and so I'm
sure I'll meet you 50. I flew out to New
York we had this incredible meeting
that's amazing
um and I think that's so interesting to
hear how the force get Laws of Power
helped him
um and how he actually said that you
know hustling on the streets was easier
in some ways than navigating the music
industry well when you're dealing with
fellow crack dealers or or drug addicts
Etc you kind of know who they are
they're kind of open books that guy he
is evil he is dead you can't trust him
right that person they're weak they're
they're just you know they're they're an
addict you know okay it's all kind of
out in the open
but an executive a record executive man
they say they love you they say you're
wonderful but in but the monsters your
back is turned they're bad-mouthing you
they're doing things to try and
negotiate you down you don't know who to
trust you don't know who you are you're
like well what is this world I've just
entered right you know so I think the
book really helped him kind of calm down
and be strategic in these situations and
think before reacting and understand
that these were kind of the games that
people were being played right on him
and what I think I know the answer now
after this but which industry would you
say
you says most important for implementing
these specific Tools in order to succeed
and not be you know pushed over music
industry real estate property banking
acting which is it
it's hard to discriminate I remember
once
um I was in Washington a booked where
the 48 Laws of Power
and I was in um one of the Departments
that I think was the voice of America
this woman came running up to me and she
goes thank you so much for writing this
book this is exactly what the
bureaucratic world of Washington is like
it is so evil it's so many people you
never trust your book helped me I
remember I was in San Diego once and
this woman came running up to me she
goes thank Robert thank you so much for
this book she was in the non-profit
world she said the non-profit world you
wouldn't believe Robert is so
Machiavellian people are constantly
jockeying for power and position the art
world you know which I know fairly well
is incredibly competitive incredibly
Machiavelli there's no place on Earth
it's not like that right maybe if you're
a a elementary school teacher no that's
probably still like that my mom's a
teacher actually I hear it's it's a
nightmare at school okay I take it back
I've dealt with athletes who said
you know professional basketball players
Robert the NBA team owners you can never
trust them they're terrible they're
awful your book helped me you know it
helped a lot so it'd be hard to say
from what I hear the record industry is
the worst one thing I will say the more
money involved
the weirder and more manipulative and
sharkier people become so the record
industry in Hollywood are dealing with
huge amounts of money right but also
business as well so what would you say
people should look out for
um to know whether to trust somebody or
not because you don't want to just go
and maybe you should go into a situation
and be highly skeptical of everybody
around you but again I personally would
find that slightly out of character so
that red flags that you should look for
how do you tell if somebody's got bad
intentions
well it's a great question and if it
were so easy then we there would be no
problems in life so sometimes we make
mistakes I make I still to this day make
mistakes but you want to increase your
odds you want to make it so that
80 percent of the time you judge people
correctly okay yes occasionally I make
mistakes I'm human as well
but
so you start off with a slight Touch of
skepticism right people have to reach a
certain barrier okay and immediately you
base things on body language first of
all on Comfort your instincts are often
incredibly powerful where and I often
that this happened with when we're
talking about seduction where women
would say you know Robert when I first
met him I was a little bit worried wary
of him there seems something didn't seem
right and then I fell for him and then
all that went out the window so often
you get a sense of people I say look at
the body language so for instance if
you're talking to someone right
how do their eyes engage right are they
really looking at you are they
constantly shifting and looking around
are they facing you with how's their
posture when they do they have an
excited look is their smile natural and
real or is it very fake and put on
what's the tone in their voice is it
excited or is it not excited you can
read all these things I have a whole
chapter in the laws of human nature
about that so a lot of it is body
language and some of it is patterns of
behavior right so if if you're dealing
with someone
and they are are late
for for an event or whatever put that in
file that in the back of your mind and
go that says something about them maybe
it was just the traffic maybe they had a
good excuse okay
but maybe not
all right and they'll say oh I'm sorry
you know I got held up then there's late
a second time all right there's a
pattern here there's something going on
and it can have other reasons they're
trying to to indicate that they feel
Superior to you in some way Etc look at
these little signs people are constantly
revealing signs about who they are about
their intentions about their level of
trustworthiness right but you're not
picking them up
so you know look at how they're how they
dress how messy or disorganized they are
I know I can speak because I'm extremely
disorganized that way but that's another
story
um so look at all of the details and
you know in a relationship situation
maybe you can let down your guard at
first Etc and not you're not I don't
want you to be paranoid in life because
that's a problem and certainly it's only
a minority of people you need to be wary
of but in your initial stages have just
a touch of wariness and kind of
scrutinize people and be aware that
appearances can be deceptive that's the
most important thing
humans are Masters at acting they're
Masters at wearing a mask that fooling
you with a particular appearance of
being nice and sweet Etc toxic people
don't go around saying I'm toxic here
look at me they've learned how to be
very Charming right yeah
so don't trust appearances and the other
thing I'd say is if people have one
quality that's very strong
like this man is hyper masculine or this
person is extremely confident
etc etc they're disguising the opposite
often
right or the I this person is a saint
they're so good they're so wonderful
they're hiding the fact there's
something else going on it's just that
it's the extremes that I'm talking about
not if someone just is normally
confident but so hyper they have to you
know exude this yeah overcompensating
for it so read those these are all these
signs Etc we spoke Alia about um the
laws of human nature and the work that
went into that um and I saw a podcast
that you were talking about and you're
sort of saying how
the stress that you were under was
potentially sort of influenced the the
stroke that you had so I want to talk
about the stress that went into writing
that book you said you're a very
ambitious person and nothing no no
illness no no nothing would stop you
from writing that book so how do you
deal with that ambition and balance the
stress
well it could have been better at it I
probably should have
relaxed at times and taken more time off
which I'm not good at
but um I wanted to write a really
important book I wanted to help people
and I wanted to write the book that I
thought I was capable of
and so it was going to take a toll on my
body every time I finish a book
particularly since the war book I have a
feeling like God I'm on death's death's
door I pushed myself too hard Robert be
careful
and finally I did push myself too hard
and I almost died from it
um
but you know it was also a set of
circumstances which I don't know how
interesting it is it's just
um I had been walking in the park nearby
excuse me and I got a a wasp sting in my
neck
at the time I didn't pay attention to it
and then about 10 days later my whole
chest got inflamed it was excruciating
so I went to the doctor and they gave me
what's called Prednisone which is a
cortisone thing which raises your blood
pressure
the stroke that I had was a blood clot
in my neck exactly where the beat the
wasp sting was so there was some
bad circumstances that kind of
contributed to it but probably I've been
pushing myself too too hard
and you know it's it's a constant um
subject that I have to talk to my wife
was talking to me earlier today about
just relax and and just kind of hug
yourself she didn't use that kind of the
kind of syrupy language but just kind of
sit back and realize what you've
achieved and don't push yourself so hard
just kind of enjoy it more you know sort
of thing I'm not good I'm not good at
everything you know that's something I'm
bad and I'm working on and since my
stroke believe me I've really had to
slow down it's been very difficult I've
had to be much more patient but
um I don't regret it because I don't
regret anything in life but
um I wrote the book that I wanted
I paid a price for it but
um I'm alive
you know and I'm still
exercising I'm still doing things I love
I'm just limited but I'm alive so it's a
blessing as well and you said you feel
like the stroke saved your life in some
way because it forced you to slow down
you yeah well you know oftentimes I keep
thinking because I would like
travel and drive my car and ride my bike
and swimming and I would push myself
like
you know I was doing things that were
kind of like risky
and I could have first of all I could
have easily had the stroke when I was
alone my wife was in the car when I was
driving at the time that saved my life
so I could have easily died by several I
could have been a terrible car accident
I could have crashed my bicycle I could
have done all sorts of other things you
know because I don't I wasn't too
careful
so um in some ways it was a wake-up call
that probably saved me in the end I
remember once this so this will sound a
little woo-woo but
um about eight years ago I was supposed
to go to Brazil for a book draw I was so
excited and the Night Before Our Cat
disappeared the cat that I loved more
than well not more than anything but I
adored Brutus
um
and we couldn't find him and like it was
like 36 hours later we were freaking out
and I was supposed to leave the next day
for Brazil we were it was the middle of
the night we were searching for him and
my wife thought she heard a faint meow
and he was like trapped underneath the
house and I jumped over their fence of
the neighbor's house and I'd rescue him
and I landed on a rock and I broke my
foot splintered it and all sorts of
pieces right
no Brazil trip I have a feeling to this
day
something bad would have happened on
that person
who knows I'm just maybe I'm just
talking to myself no I I'm like that I
also think if I'm pushed in another
Direction in life it's to sort of save
me and protect me from something worse
um so yeah that's I'm not alone no
you're not alone I think a lot of people
do I think that even might be human
nature we rationalize things to make it
feel better for us yeah I know it's not
real but yeah I think I think it's
something that we do um so you're
working on a book right now can you tell
us a little bit about it yeah yes
um
I've kind of alluded to it in earlier
books so the last chapter of the 50th
law of the book I did with 50 Cent
is about confronting your mortality and
death in the last chapter in the laws of
human nature paradoxically enough is
about that in three months later I
nearly die
and they talk about I talk in those
chapters about the sublime
which I compared to
um
it's kind of a doorway that's what the
word means and you're peeking through a
doorway to something else in life to
another realm to another possibility to
something that you don't normally think
about or experience like death what lies
on the other side of death what is it
through that door and to touch that
doorway is incredibly exciting
it's like it makes you feel alive again
makes you understand why your life it
changes everything people have had
near-death experiences Etc okay but I
wanted to apply that idea to everything
in life how
normally we live in these little bubbles
particularly now with our phones Etc
where our worlds get so small and shrunk
and where all we look at is Instagram
our Instagram feed you know or whatever
it is that you look at
and we're so our worlds are shrinking
and shrinking and shrinking and at the
same time
the science is opening up these insane
wonders about the cosmos about black
holes about the origins of the universe
about the inner lives of animals about
Evolution about our brains Etc
and while the our world could be
expanding it's shrinking and we should
open our minds up to what I call the
sublime things that we haven't thought
of before or felt before or experienced
and so each chapter deals with some
aspect that is like that so the first
chapter is about the origin of the
cosmos and how you can have like a
cosmic Consciousness the second chapter
is about evolution
you know just stop and think sometime
how it is so strange that you and I are
alive right now sitting here in Los
Angeles in the studio
when 80 million years ago there were
dinosaurs roaming the planet
and somehow everything turned in a
certain particular way where the
dinosaurs disappeared and mammals
emerged and from mammals came primates
and then us and if one thing had gone
wrong we wouldn't be here
everything around us every plant
every object should strike you as being
kind of a miracle kind of strange the
world is what it is
you know and we take it so much for
granted I don't want to sound like
overly pollyanish about it because it's
it's a philosophy of life that I think
can be very profound and very uplifting
for people right and it's helped me a
lot in writing this book too because as
I said I nearly died as well
so that's the book that's the book that
I'm writing right now I'm writing a
chapter about the brain and
Consciousness and how strange the human
brain is and how we can use it for other
purposes than what we use it for
ETC so that's giving you a taste of the
book I'm so fascinated to read it um I
think your work is so interesting
um I'm somebody who wants to live a very
fulfilled life you know well you are
you're living it right now I'm doing my
best so I I go head first into this kind
of this kind of work this kind of
content
um so how can how can people follow your
work you know follow updates about the
book well
um I have a website that's like
incredibly old it's called Empower
seduction and War the end is spelled out
excuse me power seduction and war.com
and there you find links to my Instagram
Facebook Tick Tock Snapchat the whole
slew
and also all my YouTube interviews
and then there is an email address for
writing me if you will but please
understand that since my stroke I can't
type my left hand is useless so
um
it's very hard for me to write back
but I read everything people send me and
sometimes I do try and respond so if you
do that don't be angry at me and hate me
if I don't respond but there's an email
address where you can write to me
I think I've covered everything there
well social media by the way is the is
brilliant the the tick tock is brilliant
the Instagram is brilliant everything is
perfect well we can thank Stanley for
that he's my media manager and he does a
great job so shout out to Stanley there
Stanley Goldberg well I want to thank
you so much for coming on um it's such a
pleasure I really enjoyed yeah thank you
so much for coming and I'm so excited to
read it and you are actually very nice I
take it I didn't mean to imply otherwise
oh I am is that how I come across out of
interesting Karma because it's nice yeah
that's good that's good I'm happy and
not too nice though yes that's true
sometimes I can be but I'm using the
laws I find it slightly exhausting at
times because it's not natural for me
but but remember what I said yes turn
that exhausting into excitement
excitement enjoy exactly Robert thank
you so much thank you thank you so much
for watching don't forget to hit the
like button and hit the Subscribe button
so you never miss a video we will see
you all next week